j'aimerais qu'on a un petit souci là je
viens de larguer tout les sens j'ai
jamais vous vous demandez comment j'en
suis arrivée là pourtant tout avait bien
commencé et nous amuse y croit pas on
est au brésil pour rencontrer monsieur
la marque des grands os je veux faire
découvrir mon paradis terrestre mais je
vais tout le temps comme ça lui parce
que
à
ce n'est pas ce qu'on filme à la banque
alors les jeunes on va se parler dans le
coin génial maman va adorer ça
l'occupera les parties je la confie
les a pas trouvés
il n'y a plus de lumière il faut arrêter
les recherches tant que j'y suis avec
vous ils ne font rien et nous aurons
comme un moyen pour le son très jeune
âge eux c'est une corde avec des
vêtements mais ça marche super bien et a
abouti sur quoi cette fois tout âge vous
à 8 h 15 nous d'avoir voulu changer les
idées la camair d'autres conseils aux
[ __ ] ternois
en tout cas merci pour l'excursion à une
superbe année
m